cake boss buddy valastro nearly seven
months after that freak
accident that left his hand mangled
buddy is baking again
i'm feeling good my hand is coming along
i had my fifth surgery about a month ago
and it was a huge success so i can make
like a whole fist
hold my fingers straight and i got i'd
say about 75
of my strength back so you know it's
coming along
that's right there is remarkable
progress given today on rachel ray
i spoke to buddy last september just
days after shattering his dominant right
baking hand
at the time the future of his 10 million
dollar cake empire
was on the line trying to stay positive
still recovering
there's definitely a lot of pain you
know it's just a freak crazy thing
the accident occurred at his home inside
his bowling alley
but he was playing with his sons when
the pin setter got stuck when he tried
to fix it the cake boss's hand was
repeatedly impaled
for over five minutes until his older
two sons used a saw to free their dad
you instructed them on what to do it did
i
honestly i couldn't be prouder of my
sons and my family
the longer that rod was in my hand the
longer a chance that i could have lost
my hand
who would have hit my wrist forget about
i could have bled out but he told me he
didn't know if he would ever be able to
work his magic again
i might not ever be able to pipe again i
don't know
you know i i mean unfortunately i might
have to learn to do with my other hand
um you know you just don't know kev this
is kind of what the top looks like
it looks like a nice little flowery
tip that you see that clearly he's still
got it showing off his spring-inspired
decorating skills
this is a great mother's day cake you
know um you can do it for your mom
oh yeah my mom would love to see this
i'm sure